welcome back as we've been reporting
Democratic congressman john conyers
facing multiple accusations of sexual
harassment and now even Nancy Pelosi is
calling for his resignation that gets
really bad
however Conyers isn't going quietly his
attorney said quote Pelosi did not elect
the congressman and she sure as hell
will not pressure him to leave he
claimed a double standard noting that
Democrats are not calling on senator Al
Franken to resign maybe a race element
there but a new bill would abolish the
office that hides congressional
offenders and uses taxpayer money to
hush up their indiscretions we first
told you about this office of compliance
and last night I asked Majority Leader
Mitch McConnell about the unmasking of
names would he be in favor of it alleged
abusers and he said this well I think my
attitude about this I want to wait to
see what the women of the Senate
recommend on that any other issues are
we talking about so so it could be
possible that well wait to see what the
women of the Senate recommend on that
issue why just the women of the Senate
all right listen everybody they're in a
very good position take the lead some
men are involved as well on both sides
and tonight we have some new clarity on
the identity of the alleged harasser
'he's on Capitol Hill whose settlements
were paid from the slush fund a whopping
$100,000 went to two staffers of
disgraced Democrat congressman Eric
Massa who was forced to resign joining
me now for reaction all this congressman
Ron De Santis Republican from Florida
he's a co-sponsor of the Congressional
Accountability and hush fund Elimination
Act I can't believe there's an actual
intact with hush fund in the title
Congressman De Santis take it away I
mean Mitch McConnell would not commit to
unmasking the names there as far as I
could tell at least well think about it
Laura you have a situation where members
of Congress can commit misconduct the
taxpayers will pay for their misconduct
and then it's all kept secret so what
kind of behavior are you trying to
promote and here's the thing about the
offenders this is taxpayer dollars you
as a taxpayer have a right to know how
your money is being spent so my bill
would unveil the claims that were
brought the amount and then the
perpetrator and the American public
deserves that that information there's
no way that that should be secret
there are any other funds that we should
know about on Capitol Hill that have
you've come across so we're actually my
staff we're researching to get all of
them because what happens is they'll do
one permanent appropriation so just a
pot of money that exists outside the
budget process so people like did you
know this was there I was like no I
don't know it's here because it's not in
the budget it's not in our
appropriations bill it shouldn't be
allowed molars funding is actually DOJ
God is outside I think that's a bad
interpretation I don't think he's
entitled to that that's what they're
relying on one of these he can spend
basically as much money as he wants bait
without and without any real oversight I
mean justice could tell him to stop but
they've not shown any inclination of
doing so he can hire as many people as
he got 16 prosecutors at all one day
what have they found so far they have
that for the OJ Simpson murder case or
Oklahoma City or anything case no Kate
Steinle
accuser basically got off nothing maybe
a couple of years possession of a
firearm as a felon illegal immigrant
deported five times sanctuary state
sanctuary city policies you're taking
this well the the verdict obviously is a
disaster but the root cause of this is
which exactly what you said it's the
fact that we did have control over our
borders and you had a sanctuary city
where he could return knowing he'd be
put back on the streets so I think
Congress needs to look at this now say
we have a spending bill coming up in
December we've got to totally defund
sanctuary cities in that spending bill I
mean thinking about her family tonight
and victimized once again their hearts
broken again I mean there's no justice
here well you remember what Jimmy o Shaw
and his son in California they releasing
these illegal immigrants right back onto
the street even though they were in
custody and his son gets killed as a
high school senior gonna go play
football so how many more of these
stories do we need to have before we
actually take action outside in a second
what the lawyer for the for the for
whatever his name is I forgot this
forgot that evil persons name but a
graceful verdict that's what Trump
tweeted a graceful verdict and the Cates
a disgraceful verdict in the Kate
Steinle case
no wonder the people of our country are
so angry with illegal immigration I
think he's right about that
we had the lawyer for the accused
tonight we had played a sound byte
earlier where he said this vindicates
basically the rights of illegal
immigrants to be here in the United
States and to stop demeaning immigrants
always conflating illegal immigrants
with immigrants he what he gave went on
and on with this impassioned statement
about how this demonstrates that we have
real justice in the United States for
people no matter what color their skin
making it a racial issue and it was
nothing nothing further than the truth
the guy should have been in the country
that's why we'd get the statistics from
the Obama administration how many
illegal immigrants did they release who
then went on to commit crimes it's I
don't know what percentage of that is
committing crimes but every one of those
crimes you could say had we enforced the
law as written
none of those crimes would have happened
that's just the bottom line with this
last night I met Mitch McConnell in this
interview actually said that he was in
favor of ending chain migration and was
in favor basically of the Rae's Act
which I hadn't heard him say before that
was actually very heartening to a lot of
our viewers and it was almost a little
surprising to me it's sounding really
conservative on immigration yeah I mean
you know McConnell obviously viewed as a
quintessential establishment Republican
the Republican establishment has never
embraced things like the raise act or
ending chain migration so things are
changing obviously driven by the
President of the United States
so his agenda perhaps will actually be
pursued it's regarding it's a way to
unite the party because that's where our
bases on these issues our base is not
with the open borders folks so it looks
like corker tonight might be throwing a
monkey wrench into the tax reform bill
over in the Senate any thoughts there
look we we every Republican runs for
office saying the tax codes a disaster
we pay too much we have a chance to do
something tiring right so you're not
gonna face the voters again and you want
to try to deep-six this what because you
have a personal beef with the president
that's not what we're here to do we're
here to represent our constituents the
Senate needs to get this done and end
the drought the legislative drought that
they've been in all year it would raise
taxes by three hundred fifty billion
dollars more if this goes down what 2018
prediction well obviously I mean I think
our base will be deflated the big we
elect you guys and whatever yeah no it's
not
it's not gonna be good for the economy
the horrific congressman de santé is
always great to see you thank you so
much